revenge might be a dish best served cold
but these films all delivered red-hot
justice whether it was an entire films
worth of elaborate plotting and
execution or a single moment of sweet
revenge here are some of the greatest
acts of revenge in movies ever the gift
Joel Edgerton made his big-screen
directorial debut with 2015's the gift
where he plays Gordo a seemingly sad
sack who runs into an old high-school
acquaintance named Simon played by Jason
Bateman
Gordo turns into something of an
unwanted shadow for the man and his wife
Robyn but eventually Gordo spookiness
becomes more worrisome than weird as
Simon secrets come to life Gordo steps
up his psyche unraveling campaign of
terror including sending Simon
disturbing footage of his wife being
drugged by Gordo nine months before the
birth of her baby in retaliation for a
casual act of cruelty that caused Gordo
unfathomable pain he makes Simon
question whether or not his child is
actually even his now that's what you
call a mind game the help the help from
2011 is set in the middle of Mississippi
during the civil rights movement Octavia
Spencer plays Minnie the long-suffering
maid to the horrible hilly a
self-declared moral authority who leads
the community charge to segregate
in-home bathrooms Minnie is fired for
using the guests restroom rather than
brave a storm to access the outhouse
facilities but she makes hilly eager
words by cooking her a chocolate pie
that contains a new special ingredient
Minnie's well poof
[Music]
it sounds foul but it's actually quite a
delicious moment to watch his Hilly's
brain catches up with her ears and
understands what she's been told about
the dessert she still ravenously chowing
down inglorious basterds vigilante
justice is an essential element in many
of Quentin Tarantino's movies but
inglorious basterds tops Tarantino's
catalogue of excellent revenge moments
it's a blood-soaked take on world war
two style vengeance against some of
history's most reprehensible villains
from shoshanna's orchestrated torching
of the Fuhrer - Donnie bear Jew Donowitz
his merciless beatdown of a remorseless
SS officer - lieutenant aldo raine
carving a swastika in the hans Landis
forehead Basterds dispenses justice in
ways that only make the intense violence
that much more entertaining wanted it's
a scene that makes Jerry McGuire's
office exit speech seem like a note with
a smiley face left on the company bridge
in wanted Wesley politely announces his
departure from the corporate world
shut up and heads for the exit with his
ripped out computer keyboard in hand his
buddy and co-worker Barry who's
befuddled by what Wesley just said to
their boss goes for the high-five and
gets according to the face instead
appropriate since Barry had been
sleeping with Wesley's girlfriend
Wesley doubles down on his vengeance by
making out with a badass Beauty Fox
played by Angelina Jolie right in front
of her man on fire in the 2004 action
drama man on fire a retired CIA
operative named John Creasy played by
Denzel Washington takes a gig as the
bodyguard slash babysitter of a
nine-year-old girl named Peeta becomes a
fine but the job entails a lot more than
mere child's play when Peeta is
kidnapped
Creasy gets to work finding and
systematically slaughter in her captors
in the movies most memorable revenge
scene Creasy tides a potential kidnapper
down to a car and well see for highly
explosive you put them all together you
got a bomb not very sophisticated but
very powerful that's what you have in
your ass the perp spills the beans but
Creasy is unforgiving never mess with
Denzel Road to Perdition this
depression-era drama Road to Perdition
follows mafia enforcer Michael Sullivan
played by Tom Hanks seeking justice for
his wife and child who were murdered by
his mentor son Connor played by Daniel
Craig with the surviving son in tow
Sullivan works his way through the
deadly crime syndicate to find Connor
and make him pay the journey is filled
with treachery and devastation but in
the end the parties who deserve it get
there's even Sullivan whose son watches
and pay the ultimate sacrifice for his
life of violence the Shawshank
Redemption when the word redemption is
in the title you could probably be sure
that things will turn around by the end
of the movie and the 40 year old saga of
Andi 2 frames false imprisonment is no
exception while the man who actually
committed the murders for which Andi is
convicted is eventually imprisoned he
isn't the one who earns andis true wrath
instead at Shawshank warden Norton who
has the opportunity to free and
after evidence of his wrongful
imprisonment comes to light instead of
doing so Norton punishes Andy further
all the while relying on Andy to cook
his books so he could launder money
under the name Randall Stephens after
Andy escaped to freedom he adopts the
Randall Stephens alias to siphon off the
wardens ill-gotten loot and turns
evidence of Norton's crimes over to the
feds
leaving the warden no choice but to off
himself in his own office John wick a
grieving widower receives a strange
present one day an adorable little puppy
the final gift from his dead wife and a
chance for him to start over and
appreciate life despite his loss that's
how 2014's John wick starring Keanu
Reeves starts out it doesn't take long
however for the son of a Russian mob
boss to break into wicks house kill his
puppy and beat him to a pulp all so he
can steal his car big mistake because he
stole John Wick's car sir and killed his
dog
oh that's when the viewers find out who
John wick really is one of the most
fearsome and effective hit men to ever
retire from the business people keep
asking if I'm back and I haven't really
had an answer but now yeah I'm taking on
back
what follows is one of the best most
action-packed revenge movies in recent
history featuring wick taking out the
Russian mob piece-by-piece
when wick finally catches up to the
creep who killed his dog he takes out
his bodyguards with a sniper rifle
blows up his getaway cars and shoots him
in the guts all before finally putting a
bullet in his head while he's
mid-sentence thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which revenge scenes are your
favorite
[Music]